To show that equivalence is undecidable, we should first start out with a program
for which we want to decide the halting problem, and that should be P.
We start out with the step here, and then we add a second program and that program is called P‘
and it goes into an infinite loop.
No matter what input, this program is just programmed to always go into an infinite loop.
Once we have those two programs P and P‘, we run them through the algorithm
that decides equivalence and what that will do is it will basically ask--
does the program P for which we want to decide the halting problem do the same thing
as the program that always goes into an infinite loop.
And then, of course, that means if the two programs are indeed equivalent,
then P will also go into an infinite loop because all that P‘ is doing is it always goes into an infinite loop
and we don't even need the other two building blocks because we have now shown
that you can use equivalence to solve the halting problem.
You just compare any program for which you want to decide the halting problem to a program
that always goes into an infinite loop and if they do the same thing, then they are equivalent.
So you know that P will not halt, and if they are equivalent, well then P halts.
Now, this was certainly one of the tougher quizzes in this course so congratulations for figuring it out,
but of course I also trust that by now you have learned the ropes of theoretical computer science.
You revert here is that I will give you a third proof of undecidability for free.